Le sujet de ce soir, c'est un sujet qui est important dans la vie des croyants en tant que tel.
Et je pense que c'est un sujet où chacun de nous, nous avons été confrontés à cela une ou plusieurs fois.
Et même depuis notre conversion, on a déjà pu être confrontés à cela.
Quand j'étais plus jeune, un des passages de la Bible qui m'avait marqué, c'est le passage qui sert d'introduction à ça.
Et le proverbe 29, verset 25, pour ceux qui connaissent, c'est la crainte de l'homme tend un piège, mais celui qui se confie en l'éternel est protégé.
Ça, c'est le proverbe 29, verset 25.
Et c'est un peu le verset central par rapport à ce cours.
Et donc, comme Azaria nous a aidés pour ce soir, même si j'ai ça de dos, mais vous voyez donc.
Donc la première partie, nous allons voir à travers plusieurs parties aussi aujourd'hui un peu, on va plutôt définir aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que c'est la peur de l'homme.
Comment nous avons pu voir la peur de l'homme dans notre vie.
Nous allons voir qu'est-ce que les écritures disent de la peur de l'homme.
Et de quelle façon nous devons aborder cela.
Et à la fin, quand nous allons parler de quelle façon nous devons aborder la peur de l'homme, la crainte de l'homme, nous rentrerons un peu plus en détail dans la suite de l'étude.
Mais aujourd'hui, c'est une introduction.
Donc, pour ce premier un, cette première partie, où et comment nous pouvons faire face à la peur de l'homme.
La peur de l'homme, c'est quelque chose qu'on le verra par la suite quand on va chercher à avoir les origines.
La peur de l'homme prend son origine dans la chute.
Dès le moment où Adam et Ève vont pêcher dans le jardin, à partir de ce moment, va se développer dans leur cœur une crainte, une peur de Dieu même.
Et qui va même conduire à ce que finalement cela se propage à eux.
Et quand nous le voyons déjà, nous voyons cette peur de l'homme lorsque Dieu vient chercher, après qu'ils aient péché, Dieu vient chercher Adam et Ève.
Et à un moment, ils cherchent Adam et Ève, ils se sont cachés.
Ils se sont cachés parce qu'ils ont eu peur.
Et donc, la peur de l'homme, c'est quelque chose qui traverse l'histoire de l'humanité.
C'est quelque chose qui est universel.
On peut parler de certaines choses, on ne va peut-être pas comprendre.
Mais quand nous parlons de la peur de l'homme, chacun de nous peut savoir de quoi il s'agit.
La peur de l'homme peut prendre plusieurs formes.
Elle s'étend à tous les aspects de notre vie, à tous les niveaux d'interaction avec les gens, avec autrui.
Des gens que nous connaissons, des inconnus, des gens dont on ne se soucie pas vraiment.
Même de l'opinion qu'ils peuvent avoir de nous, mais nous allons développer une certaine peur.
Je pense même déjà en prenant l'exemple que chacun de nous, nous avons pu vivre ça.
Et surtout dans le cadre d'EBN.
À un moment, je me souviens, quand nous allions au restaurant, on pouvait se retrouver à 10 ou 15 dans un restaurant.
On prenait des tables de restaurant.
15 même si c'était petit, parce qu'à un moment, on n'avait même plus de place.
Et il y avait toujours un moment.
Il y a un moment où, après les commandes, il faut qu'on prie.
Il faut qu'on prie pour baigner le repas.
Et souvent, on est entouré de personnes, d'autres clients et autres.
Et il se peut un moment où il va falloir incliner la tête pour remercier le Seigneur pour le repas au restaurant.
Il y a des moments, et je me souviens même sur les premières fois, quand j'étais plus jeune, je me souviens que j'étais avec un pasteur.
Il était toujours en train de parler de l'Évangile.
Il était toujours en train de nous exhorter.
Même quand on est rentré dans un taxi, une fois qu'on est rentré dans un taxi, il ne faisait que parler de la parole de Dieu.
J'étais un peu gêné parce que j'avais honte.
J'avais le chauffeur de taxi qui comprenait.
Mais lui, il était tellement libre en train d'évangéliser.
Et donc, il y a des moments où on peut sentir un peu cette gêne où on va regarder autour de nous pour nous assurer peut-être que les gens ne regardent pas.
Et puis, on va vite prier, toutes ces choses-là.
Pourquoi on peut avoir honte d'être vu en train de faire des choses qui pourraient nous identifier comme chrétiens,
ou encore plus devant des gens dont on ne se soucie pas de l'opinion ?
Parce qu'à un moment, les gens dans le restaurant, vous n'allez pas les revoir de toute votre vie.
Eh bien, un peu comme Pierre qui a renié le Seigneur Jésus-Christ devant une simple servante,
notre peur de l'homme n'est pas toujours guidée par une logique cohérente.
La peur de l'homme ne se limite pas seulement à la façon dont nous agissons ou à ce que nous disons.
Elle est également liée à ce que nous choisissons de ne pas dire ou de ne pas faire.
Ainsi, par exemple, lorsqu'on va réagir au conflit, on peut manifester une tendance à craindre l'homme plus que Dieu.
On peut ne pas aimer aborder le péché des autres.
On peut même éviter des conversations difficiles de peur que les gens aient une opinion négative de nous.
On peut même préférer continuer à subir un tort de quelqu'un plutôt que de nous emporter contre lui
ou d'ailleurs de nous attaquer à son péché selon la Bible.
Pourquoi on réagit ainsi ?
On peut avoir l'impression d'être un artisan de paix sans vouloir semer la zizanie,
mais trop souvent, on est plutôt amoureux de la paix plutôt qu'un artisan de la paix.
Et on va souvent préférer que les gens aient une bonne opinion de nous plutôt que d'aborder le problème
qu'on peut percevoir avec honnêteté et parfois même avec douleur.
Un autre exemple.
Là, je prends quelques exemples.
Là, on va rentrer un peu dans quelques exemples où on voit cette manifestation de la peur et pourquoi.
Le mariage, pour tous ceux qui sont mariés ou pour ceux qui ont pu aussi observer,
le mariage est aussi une façon d'éprouver la peur de l'homme.
D'un côté, dans le mariage, notre vie va être beaucoup plus exposée à l'autre.
Et pourtant, nous allons chercher encore plus à nous cacher.
Dans certains cas, même vis-à-vis de notre conjoint, on ne veut pas que notre conjoint nous connaisse comme nous pouvons être.
Ainsi, il y a des moments où on peut dissimuler un achat que le conjoint désapprouverait.
Pendant les soldes, on ne va pas lui dire à un moment où on a...
Ou bien on va le mettre devant le fait accompli.
On peut dissimuler un emploi du temps surchargé.
On peut même dissimuler certains péchés.
Peut-être que nous craignions que si quelqu'un d'autre savait ce que notre conjoint a fait de nous,
les gens auraient une opinion différente de nous.
Donc, le mariage, et on va même dire que le mariage est l'une des relations clés que le Seigneur utilise
pour nous aider à voir et à surmonter notre peur des autres.
Où il peut être le lieu où nous cédons le plus à notre peur des autres.
Un autre lieu aussi, on peut voir ça, c'est l'Église.
L'Église est un autre lieu où le Seigneur nous aide à le craindre davantage.
De base, le Seigneur nous aide à le craindre davantage au sein de l'Église.
Le Seigneur nous aide à moins craindre les autres et à les aimer davantage.
Pourtant, c'est souvent un lieu où notre peur des bonnes opinions peut devenir prédominante.
On cherche à paraître mature ou équilibrée.
On pense que les autres autour de nous ont tout pour eux,
ce qui nous empêche de partager honnêtement notre vie avec eux,
parce que souvent on a peur de la comparaison.
Lorsque nous laissons nos relations à l'Église être marquées par la peur des autres,
nous montrons que nous ne comprenons vraiment pas qui est l'autre,
que nous ne comprenons pas qui est Dieu,
et que nous n'avons pas une image juste de nous-mêmes.
Et sur ce point, je voudrais souvent souligner,
parce que souvent j'ai entendu des frères et sœurs qui vont dire à un moment,
« Moi, je ne prie pas à l'Église parce que les autres prient mieux que moi,
les autres font des prières beaucoup plus sages et autres. »
Ce n'est pas biblique.
Bien sûr, il a attendu de nous de pouvoir prier,
mais à un moment, ce que le Seigneur attend de nous,
c'est que nous prions selon la parole.
Donc si ta prière fait deux phrases,
mais qu'elle est en accord avec la parole, c'est suffisant.
Mais souvent, notre peur…
Voilà un exemple frappant souvent.
À UBN, j'ai entendu ça plusieurs fois.
Des frères et sœurs qui disent « Je ne veux pas prier là. »
Parce qu'après avoir entendu telle prière,
je ne vois pas comment je vais être digne.
Mais ce n'est pas à l'homme que tu dois rendre compte.
La prière, tu la fais à Dieu.
Édouard, alors je ne sais pas si je prononce bien,
Édouard Welch, je pense,
qui est un psychologue chrétien renommé,
pose, et là, ça va nous permettre un peu à identifier,
toujours dans cette attitude d'identification.
Il pose un certain nombre de questions
pour nous aider à diagnostiquer notre peur de l'homme.
Donc le titre du livre, je crois, c'est
« When the men are big and God is small. »
Donc quand les hommes sont grands,
quand les gens sont grands, les hommes sont grands
et que Dieu est petit dans la vision humaine.
Donc peut-être si un jour vous lirez le livre,
c'est des références, vous pouvez trouver.
Donc je crois à page 14-16,
il donne un peu ces...
Voilà quelques exemples pour nous permettre encore
de mieux comprendre.
Si on se disait à un moment,
mais est-ce que moi je vis la peur de l'homme,
est-ce que c'est la crainte de l'homme ?
Voilà quelques points.
Est-ce que vous avez déjà subi la pression sociale ?
De quelle manière, adultes, vous cédez à cette pression ?
Est-ce que...
Donc là, il prend l'exemple de Washington,
mais ça peut être valable pour nous ici à Paris.
La quête d'un CV réussit,
où chaque étape est soigneusement élaborée
et parfaitement exécutée.
Le besoin du conjoint idéal,
de l'enfant idéal, du poste idéal,
d'une maison dans le bon quartier,
de l'apparence physique,
il faut que les cheveux, les vêtements,
la silhouette idéale,
par crainte des gens,
soient toujours dans la conformité
et la liste peut être longue.
Êtes-vous trop engagé ?
Trouvez-vous difficile de dire non,
même lorsque la sagesse vous le recommande ?
Avez-vous besoin de quelque chose de votre conjoint ?
Alors là, je lis le texte,
c'était la question de vos petits amis,
donc je pense aussi que ça peut être valable
si un non-croyant entend ça.
De votre ami,
Avez-vous besoin qu'il ou elle vous écoute ?
Qu'il ou elle vous respecte ?
Avez-vous besoin qu'il ou elle remplisse un rôle que vous désirez ?
Est-ce que l'estime de soi est-elle une préoccupation essentielle pour vous ?
Avez-vous parfois l'impression d'être démasqué comme un imposteur ?
Le sentiment d'être démasqué,
même parmi ceux qui semblent avoir réussi,
est une expression de la peur de l'homme.
Est-ce que vous remettez-vous toujours en question vos décisions à cause de l'opinion des autres ?
Avez-vous peur de commettre des erreurs qui pourraient nuire à votre image aux yeux des autres ?
Avez-vous peur de prendre des risques ?
Vous sentez-vous vide ou dénué de sens ?
Est-ce que vous ressentez une soif d'amour ?
Là encore, si vous avez besoin des autres pour vous combler,
vous êtes sous leur emprise.
Êtes-vous facilement gêné ?
Vous arrive-t-il de mentir ?
Surtout les petits mensonges blancs,
les petits mensonges qui doivent passer normalement,
les dissimulations,
où vous ne mentez pas vraiment avec vos lèvres.
Est-ce que pour vous, mentir et d'autres formes d'ignorance
sont généralement des moyens de se donner une meilleure image aux yeux des autres ?
Souvent, ces genres de petits mensonges servent à dissimuler notre honte.
Est-ce que vous êtes jaloux des autres ?
Est-ce que les autres vous mettent-ils souvent en colère ou vous dépriment ?
Est-ce qu'ils vous rendent fous ?
Donc là, dans l'expression, c'est qu'on peut péter un câble.
Est-ce que vous évitez les gens ?
Là, nous étions en train de parler du régime tout à l'heure,
mais il y a des personnes qui vont faire des régimes,
il y a des personnes qui vont faire certaines choses,
pas sous le signe de la santé, mais à cause du regard des autres.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils ne vont même pas penser à leur santé,
ils vont faire parce qu'il y a le regard des autres,
il y a la pression sociale.
On fait du sport, non pas pour sa santé, mais à cause de la pression sociale.
L'objectif de cette étude que nous allons faire pendant quelques semaines,
ce sera d'explorer la signification de la peur de l'homme dans nos vies et notre culture.
Et en explorant cette peur, c'est de voir comment nous devons restaurer la perspective biblique
et rétablir la crainte de Dieu dans nos vies afin d'avoir une juste perspective sur nous-mêmes et sur les autres.
On va étudier, donc ça, ce n'est pas ce que nous allons faire ce soir,
mais ça sera approfondi dans les semaines qui vont suivre.
Nous allons étudier trois principales façons dont nous avons tendance à craindre l'homme.
Il y a la crainte du mal physique, il y a des moments, ça peut être illégitime,
on peut avoir peur des violences, des abus, des moqueries, des persécutions.
Il y a la crainte du rejet à cause du statut social, des relations et d'autres choses.
Il y a la crainte de la dénonciation.
Donc, à cause de cette crainte de l'image qu'on va ressortir,
voilà pourquoi certaines personnes vont trouver leur évasion dans des choses futiles,
ils vont être dans des jeux vidéo, dans tout ce qui contribue au divertissement,
le perfectionnisme, c'est-à-dire à cause de l'image des autres,
il faut qu'on fasse tout, qu'on paraisse comme étant la personne la plus parfaite possible,
la luxure même, pour beaucoup de personnes qui vont être dans la pornographie, dans la luxure,
ça va être le fait même, le regard des autres,
on va même avoir du mal à s'engager autre
et on va développer des choses qui sont contre ce que Dieu approuve.
Donc ça, c'était cette première partie.
Il y a en dessous, il y a la crainte.
Donc, avant de rentrer dans la deuxième partie qui nous permet justement de savoir pourquoi nous craignons l'homme,
on va déjà se poser la question.
Donc, nous voyons où peuvent se manifester les craintes, la crainte de l'homme dans nos vies,
mais on va aussi se demander la question, qui craint l'homme ?
On peut se poser la question parce qu'on peut se dire à un moment que c'est peut-être un homme qui est puissant,
quelqu'un qui a tout dans sa vie, ne va pas craindre les autres.
Mais 1 Corinthiens 10, verset 13, nous dit
« Aucune tentation ne vous est survenue qui n'ait été humaine ».
Et à partir de là, nous pouvons nous poser la question, alors, qui lutte contre la peur de l'homme ?
Eh bien, selon les Écritures, c'est un problème universel auquel tout le monde est confronté.
Et même quand nous allons le voir plus loin, certaines des figures les plus influentes de l'Écriture,
même des personnes qui vont être des modèles dans les Écritures, ont été en proie à ce combat de la crainte des hommes.
La peur de l'homme est donc un combat universel.
Cette peur ne se limite pas à la position sociale, elle ne se limite pas au statut social,
elle ne se limite pas à la personnalité.
« La crainte de l'homme concerne chacun de nous ».
La crainte de l'homme va concerner celui qui peut paraître fort,
la crainte de l'homme va concerner le faible,
la crainte de l'homme va concerner les riches et les influents,
la crainte de l'homme va concerner les pauvres et les insignifiants,
la crainte de l'homme va concerner le timide, les audacieux, le croyant ou l'incroyant.
Et donc, ce que je voudrais, pendant que nous sommes en train de rentrer dans ces points,
et même là, par rapport à ce qui a déjà été partagé,
nous devons trouver un encouragement pendant que nous sommes en train de poursuivre ces choses.
C'est toujours extrêmement encourageant pour nous,
que ce soit lorsque nous allons faire cette étude,
que ce soit pour examiner ce péché ou celui d'autrui dans notre vie,
de nous rappeler la vérité de 1 Corinthiens 10.
L'une des premières attaques de Satan, et qui va toujours faire un moment,
c'est de nous convaincre que nous sommes les seuls à lutter contre un péché particulier,
ou que notre combat est particulièrement singulier.
Et donc, à un moment, on aura même du mal à partager le combat,
parce qu'on va dire, je suis presque seul à vivre ce genre de choses,
les autres n'ont pas à vivre ça, donc c'est un combat qui me concerne,
je m'en occupe moi-même.
L'un des plus beaux aspects de l'Église,
c'est le fait que nous sommes impliqués dans la vie les uns des autres,
nous sommes impliqués par des conversations honnêtes et transparentes
avec des personnes qui, selon les conceptions du monde,
sont radicalement différentes des nôtres,
et nous allons commencer à percevoir que le combat que nous pensons être le seul à lutter,
nous allons voir un moment que nous pouvons être concernés dans l'Église,
nous tous, nous allons être concernés par ça.
Si je pensais être le seul à craindre l'homme,
quand je vais discuter avec mes frères et sœurs,
quand ils vont me raconter certaines expériences au niveau du travail ou des choses,
je vais constater que la crainte de l'homme n'est pas seulement réservée à un membre lambda de l'Église,
la crainte de l'homme concerne tout le monde au sein de l'Église,
elle va concerner le pasteur, elle va concerner le membre de l'Assemblée.
Et ça doit nous encourager à voir aussi que, vu que c'est un problème aussi universel,
c'est de comprendre aussi que le Seigneur Jésus-Christ,
c'est l'Évangile qui nous permet aussi de résoudre ce problème.
Donc, une des questions, ça vient déjà à partir de ce dont nous avons,
les questions que nous nous sommes posées,
je pense que chacun de nous peut déjà sortir un ou deux exemples dans sa vie
où il a pu manifester la crainte de l'homme.
Déjà plusieurs fois.
Je parle même, rien que sur le fait de l'évangélisation,
il y a des moments où on va avoir du mal à évangéliser
parce qu'on va craindre les hommes,
on va avoir du mal peut-être à prêcher l'Évangile
parce qu'on craint les réactions des hommes, tout ça.
Je ne parle pas d'un, il faut être sage au niveau du travail,
mais on parle vraiment d'une crainte ou un moment,
on est dans cette situation où on réfléchit
parce qu'on a peur d'être identifié comme croyant.
Donc, on peut trouver plusieurs exemples dans nos vies comme ça,
plusieurs exemples de craintes de l'homme
à partir de ce que j'ai déjà pu développer.
Sur la partie 2, donc sur la partie 1,
on a vu où et comment la crainte de l'homme peut se manifester dans nos vies.
Sur la partie 2, c'est de voir pourquoi nous craignons l'homme.
Donc, une première chose qui nous amène à cette crainte de l'homme,
ça va être l'expérience passée.
L'expérience passée va nous montrer que l'homme peut nous causer du tort,
l'homme peut nous causer de la souffrance et des difficultés.
La vie est douloureuse, ça c'est sûr,
et nous serons, ça ne va pas s'arrêter maintenant,
nous serons, on a déjà été rejetés,
nous avons déjà été exposés par des gens,
nous serons encore rejetés, nous serons encore exposés.
Et nous devons nous souvenir,
il y a un verset, ce verset aussi,
on va l'étudier pendant cette étude biblique,
où le Seigneur Jésus-Christ nous rappelle un moment
de ne pas craindre ceux qui peuvent tuer que le corps.
Mais il va nous dire un moment
qu'il faut craindre celui qui a le pouvoir même
de pouvoir nous juger,
même plus tard dans la mort.
Autrement dit, on peut nous tuer,
mais même cela n'est pas la pire chose à craindre.
Donc souvent, il y a l'expérience passée
qui nous affecte déjà,
qui nous amène à la crainte de l'homme,
à cause des rejets,
à cause des choses où nous n'avons pu être exposés.
Une autre chose qui nous amène à craindre l'homme,
ça va être l'orgueil.
Parce qu'à cause du péché,
aussi bien le pauvre que le riche,
et donc tous ceux que j'ai pu citer,
aussi bien le croyant que l'incroyant,
il va toujours nous arriver un moment dans notre vie
où nous sommes fiers,
et où nous allons être égocentriques.
L'orgueil est au cœur de la peur de l'homme.
L'orgueil ne se limite pas à celui qui a confiance en lui.
L'orgueil est au cœur de celui qui manque d'assurance
et de celui qui est codépendant.
Souvent, là, quand on va parler comme ça,
on peut se dire,
mais comment quelqu'un qui serait...
Souvent, on associe toujours cette chose de dire,
mais comment quelqu'un qui serait pauvre ou autre,
qui serait simple,
pourrait manifester de l'orgueil ?
Mais le péché même,
le péché, c'est l'orgueil.
La première manifestation de péché,
c'est Satan qui a eu de l'orgueil
et qui a été chassé du ciel.
Et l'orgueil peut se manifester.
Chaque fois, par exemple,
que quelqu'un va dire,
je décide de frauder la CAF
parce qu'il y a d'autres qui profitent
et moi, je n'ai pas,
c'est une manifestation d'orgueil.
Il y a un péché d'orgueil qui se manifeste.
Donc, nous voyons un moment
que la crainte de l'homme
peut venir de notre expérience passée,
mais la crainte de l'homme
vient aussi de l'orgueil.
Et donc, l'individu
qui va être le patron d'entreprise,
qui peut être égocentrique et agressif,
la secrétaire qui va être introvertie,
les deux vont avoir pour point commun
d'avoir un moment cette fierté
et cet égocentrisme.
Une des choses pour lesquelles
nous allons craindre l'homme
et qui peut même souvent être
beaucoup plus observée,
plus facilement,
c'est la vision des autres
qui est basée sur nos besoins.
Nous avons souvent une vision des autres
On va partir sur le fait
que nous avons besoin,
donc là, je vais dire,
j'ai besoin de son amour,
j'ai besoin de son respect
et de son intérêt,
j'ai besoin de l'obéissance
de mes enfants,
j'ai besoin de l'amitié de quelqu'un,
j'ai besoin d'une bonne église,
j'ai besoin de ses vêtements,
j'ai besoin de ce type d'éducation,
j'ai besoin d'un travail enrichissant.
C'est très facile pour nous
de passer du simple besoin
à la conviction
que nous méritons réellement quelque chose.
Un moment va partir vraiment
dans le fait,
un moment de se dire,
un moment que,
la peur de l'homme
va nous amener un moment
à nous mettre en retrait,
à ne pas aller dans le sens
de la vérité un moment
parce que nous basons
notre vision de la vie
sur le besoin
que nous avons des autres.
Et donc,
dans beaucoup de cas,
vous allez voir un moment,
on a vu beaucoup de scandales
dernièrement à Hollywood,
des femmes qui étaient agressées
et autres,
et ça s'est passé
pendant plusieurs années
et personne n'a parlé.
et quand la plupart,
on va constater pourquoi
les gens n'avaient pas parlé,
c'est parce qu'ils ne voulaient
pas perdre leur travail.
Donc,
comme ils avaient besoin
de cette personne
qui était en train
d'abuser d'autres personnes,
ils se sont tus.
C'est dans ce sens
où je voulais parler
d'une vision
qui va être basée
sur des autres,
qui est basée
sur notre besoin.
Mais toujours
dans cette continuité,
à la suite même
de cette vision
des autres basée
sur notre besoin,
pourquoi nous craignons l'homme
parce que nous avons
une vision erronée
de ce dont nous avons
réellement besoin.
Et vous voyez,
ce qui est intéressant,
c'est de voir comment
un simple verset
comme Proverbe 29,
verset 25,
peut afficher
tout ce que nous pouvons porter
dans la crainte de l'homme.
Le verset est simple.
Il dit à un moment,
celui qui craint,
celui qui,
la crainte de l'homme
tend un piège,
mais celui qui se confie
en l'éternel est protégé.
C'est un simple verset,
mais c'est un simple verset
qui peut dire beaucoup
de notre façon
de considérer l'évangile.
Et donc,
on va avoir
une autre chose
pour quand nous craignons
l'homme,
c'est la vision erronée
de ce dont nous avons
réellement besoin.
Donc,
toutes les choses
que je viens d'énoncer
peuvent être
des choses bonnes,
c'est-à-dire,
au moment,
le conjoint,
il est attendu
que notre conjoint
puisse nous manifester
de l'amour,
il est attendu
que nos conjoints,
nos amis
puissent nous manifester
du respect,
que nos enfants
puissent nous manifester
de l'obéissance,
il est attendu
de nous
que nous puissions
trouver une bonne église,
il est attendu
que nous ayons
de bons vêtements,
un bon travail,
un travail qui nous permette
de pouvoir être heureux
dans ce qu'on fait.
Bien que toutes ces choses
soient bonnes,
la question que nous
devons nous poser,
c'est de savoir
si nous en avons besoin.
Alors,
je vais m'expliquer.
On peut les désirer,
il peut avoir
de grands avantages
à les posséder,
on peut être à l'aise
avec ces choses,
mais en tant que chrétien,
je dois finalement dire
que non,
je n'en ai pas besoin.
Il peut arriver
un moment
que ces choses
ne soient pas dans ma vie,
mais la seule chose
dont j'ai vraiment besoin
dans cette vie
ou dans la suivante,
c'est que mes péchés
soient effacés
afin que je sois
réconcilié avec Dieu.
La chose la plus importante
que j'ai,
c'est que j'ai une relation
avec Dieu
qui me permette un moment
parce que j'obéis à Dieu,
cela me permet
d'avoir une conscience
qui est tranquille
vis-à-vis de Dieu,
vis-à-vis des hommes.
De plus,
la seule chose
qu'on va mériter,
ça c'est pour nous enlever
cette idée
un moment
que nous,
à cause de la crainte
de l'homme,
nous allons chercher
des choses
que nous estimons mériter.
Donc,
ça veut dire un moment
que même quand nous allons
voir l'injustice,
nous allons fermer les yeux
devant l'injustice
parce que nous avons peur
de perdre certaines choses.
Et nous devons donc
nous souvenir un moment
que la seule chose
que nous méritons vraiment,
c'est de passer
l'éternité en enfer
pour les péchés
que nous avons commis.
C'est la seule chose
que nous pouvons mériter.
Mais la grâce de Dieu
s'est manifestée.
Là encore,
Édouard Welch
va nous dire encore,
là-dessus,
va nous dire,
« Si nous pensons
que le péché
est superficiel,
nous ne comprenons pas
sa véritable nature.
Lorsque les besoins
psychologiques,
plutôt que le péché,
sont perçus
comme notre problème
principal,
non seulement
notre perception
de nous-mêmes
est affectée,
mais l'Évangile
lui-même
est transformé.
Une théorie des besoins
suggère que l'Évangile
vise avant tout
à répondre
à des besoins
psychologiques,
à répondre
à des besoins psychologiques.
Autrement dit,
l'Évangile vise
à résoudre
notre problème
d'estime de soi.
Ça, c'est une théorie
qui veut,
ça c'est une théorie
à un moment,
nous faire suggérer
à un moment
que l'Évangile soit là
pour résoudre
notre problème
d'estime de soi,
que l'Évangile serait là
pour combattre
notre tendance
à ressasser
nos échecs.
Il y a une théorie
des besoins
qui va nous faire
comprendre à un moment
que l'Évangile
serait comme une déclaration
de l'amour de Dieu
affirmant que Dieu
ne fait pas de bêtises
et cela peut nous
bien nous paraître.
Mais ce n'est pas ça
l'Évangile.
La bonne nouvelle
de Jésus
n'a pas pour but
de nous donner
une bonne image
de nous-mêmes.
Au contraire,
la parole de Dieu
est là pour nous rendre
humbles.
Et ce que je constatais
pendant que j'étais
en train de préparer
l'étude,
je constatais à un moment
que la parole de Dieu
est là pour nous aider
à comprendre
pourquoi nous avons
besoin de Dieu
chaque jour.
Chaque jour,
plus nous avançons,
plus nous allons constater
combien nous sommes pécheurs
à une idée
que nous n'imaginions pas.
Et nous allons voir
de chaque fois
pourquoi nous avons
de plus en plus besoin
de la grâce de Dieu
et pourquoi nous allons
chérir cette grâce de Dieu.
Dans Esaïe 6,
par exemple,
la présence de Dieu
a d'abord détruit
l'image qu'Esaïe
avait de lui-même.
Et puis,
cette présence de Dieu
l'a purifiée
et libérée de lui-même
et de ses propres désirs pécheurs.
Je vous invite à relire
Esaïe 6
lorsque Dieu appelle Esaïe.
Après sa purification
et sa libération symbolique,
Esaïe a été libéré
et il s'est moins préoccupé
de lui-même
et davantage
du plan de Dieu.
Et on peut voir
cette même chose
avec Ézéchiel.
La vision de Dieu,
quand Dieu apparaît
à Ézéchiel,
c'est pour lui montrer
son état de péché,
ce n'est pas pour
réussir son estime de soi.
Parce que finalement,
quand vous voyez
les choses qu'Ézéchiel a faites,
elles ne sont pas brillantes
pour l'estime de soi.
Mais ce qu'il avait constaté,
c'est que ça l'a délivré
de l'importance
qu'il attachait à son image.
Et à un moment,
ça lui a permis
d'accomplir le ministère
auquel Dieu l'appelait.
Jésus n'est pas mort
pour augmenter
notre estime de soi.
Il est plutôt mort
pour glorifier le Père
en rachetant les hommes
de la malédiction du péché.
Bien sûr,
la croix a de nombreux bienfaits,
notamment celui
de ne plus être exclu
de la présence de Dieu
et de vivre en intimité
avec le Dieu trois fois saint.
Mais la croix répond
à notre problème de péché,
elle répond
à notre besoin spirituel.
Donc,
par rapport à ces points
que nous avons évoqués,
en réexaminant nos besoins
et nos mérites réels,
nous pouvons nous réorienter
vers celui
qui a enduré la souffrance,
le rejet et la honte.
C'est-à-dire un moment,
quand nous allons avoir affaire
à la crainte de l'homme,
nous allons avoir affaire
à la peur de la souffrance,
du rejet et de la honte,
où est-ce que nous allons
trouver notre plus grande
espérance en regardant
à la croix.
Tout au long
de cette étude,
nous allons examiner
la peur de l'homme
à travers le prisme
de l'Évangile.
Lorsque nous affrontons
la peur de l'homme
indépendamment de l'œuvre
de Christ
sur la croix,
lorsque nous allons
l'affronter avec des cours
de développement personnel,
des choses comme ça,
ça peut nous apporter
un soulagement temporaire
et ça peut nous apporter
un regain de confiance
au travers de ce que
nous avons lu et autres,
mais ça n'atteindra jamais
la solution essentielle
dont nous avons besoin.
La solution essentielle,
c'est un cœur
qui est transformé
par l'Évangile.
S'il n'y a pas un cœur
qui est transformé
par l'Évangile,
même ce non-croyant
que vous connaissez
qui va vous dire
un moment,
moi, grâce au développement
personnel,
je suis maintenant zen.
Vous allez voir un jour
que cette même personne
qui vous dit
qu'elle est notamment zen,
c'est cette même personne
qui un jour va piquer
la pire crise de colère.
La seule chose
que nous devons réaliser
à un moment,
c'est que nous avons besoin
de la grâce de Dieu
pour pouvoir traiter
le rejet,
la souffrance,
la honte.
Et lorsque nous nous laissons
la croix de Christ,
ça veut dire un moment,
même un exemple pratique,
il y a des personnes
à un moment
qui sont parties
d'une église
parce que des gens
ne leur avaient pas
dit bonjour.
Donc à un moment,
leur estime de soi
a été touchée
parce que je suis venu,
les gens ne m'ont pas
dit bonjour,
ce n'est pas une église
qui aime,
je m'en vais.
Ça,
c'est une mauvaise compréhension
de l'évangile.
S'il croyait avoir compris
l'évangile,
il n'a pas compris l'évangile
parce qu'il lui suffit
de regarder ce que
le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
a vécu à la croix.
Lui qui était censé
être avec tous ses disciples,
les disciples l'ont abandonné,
tout le monde l'a abandonné,
il y avait juste quelques femmes
qui étaient avec lui.
Le Seigneur Jésus-Christ,
le Dieu
qui a créé l'univers,
a subi la souffrance,
le rejet,
la honte à la croix.
Il y a même des gens
qui sont venus se moquer de lui
en lui disant,
mais descends de la croix
si tu es Dieu.
Mais pourtant,
qu'est-ce qu'il a dit à un moment ?
Père, pardonne-leur
car ils ne savent pas
ce qu'ils font.
Donc,
nos méthodes personnelles,
nos méthodes humaines
peuvent nous aider
à un certain point
à trouver une certaine forme
de paix vis-à-vis du rejet,
mais ce ne sera
qu'une solution temporelle.
La solution la plus légitime,
la plus essentielle,
ce sera toujours
que nos yeux,
notre cœur soit transformé,
que nos yeux puissent voir
l'Évangile.
Et à ce propos,
nous allons maintenant
venir sur la troisième partie.
vous pouvez voir
qu'est-ce que les Écritures disent
au sujet de la crainte de l'homme.
Si nous voulons mieux comprendre
la peur de l'homme,
nous devons nous tourner
vers les Écritures.
Donc,
le premier point,
c'est celui que je vous ai dit
au début.
La crainte de l'homme,
la peur de l'homme
apparaît dès le moment
où Adam et Ève
pêchent dans le jardin.
Je vous donne les références,
je peux même les lire là.
Genèse 3, versets 6 à 7.
La femme vit que le fruit de l'arbre
était bon à manger
et agréable à la vue
et qu'il était précieux
pour ouvrir l'intelligence.
Elle en prit
et en mangea.
Elle en donna aussi
à son mari
qui était avec elle
et il en mangea.
Alors leurs yeux
à tous deux s'ouvrirent
et y reconnurent
qu'ils étaient nus
et cousirent des feuilles
de figuier
et s'enfirent des ceintures.
Voilà la première manifestation
de la peur
dans l'histoire humaine.
Elle vient avec la chute.
Avant qu'ils ne mangent
ce fruit
et vous voyez que
pourquoi ils vont manger
le fruit,
c'est parce que
Satan leur ment
en leur disant un moment
avec un péché d'orgueil,
vous serez des dieux.
Vous allez même voir
que ce dieu
vous raconte des mensonges
mais quand vous aurez mangé
le fruit,
vous allez être
à la même stature
que lui,
l'orgueil.
Que disent les Écritures
de la crainte de l'homme ?
C'est que
la crainte de l'homme
trouve son origine
dans la chute.
La crainte de l'homme,
c'est une vision
à court terme.
C'est-à-dire
quand nous traînons l'homme,
c'est que nous n'arrivons
pas à voir plus loin
par rapport à quelque chose.
Et voilà,
ça c'était la référence.
On a lu là tout à l'heure
ce que le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
dit dans Luc 12,
versets 4 à 5.
On pourrait même reprendre
Proverbe 29,
verset 25
qu'on a cité.
Mais dans Luc 12,
4 à 5,
je vous le dis,
mes amis,
ne craignez pas
ceux qui tuent le corps
et qui après cela
ne peuvent rien faire de plus.
Mais je vous montrerai
qui vous devez craindre.
Craignez celui
qui après avoir tué le corps
a le pouvoir
de vous jeter dans la géhenne.
Oui,
je vous le dis,
craignez-le.
La Bible nous dit
que la crainte de l'homme
c'est un piège destructeur.
Et là,
on peut reprendre
Proverbe 29,
verset 25.
La crainte des hommes
est un piège,
mais celui qui se confie
en l'éternel est protégé.
Que disent les Écritures ?
Encore,
c'est que c'est le contraire
de l'amour.
Et on a un peu évoqué ça
au début quand on parlait
un peu même
dans la gestion des conflits
par crainte des hommes.
Comment on va gérer
certains conflits ?
1 Jean 4, verset 18 nous dit
Il n'y a pas de crainte
dans l'amour,
mais l'amour parfait
bannit la crainte,
car la crainte
est liée au châtiment.
Celui qui craint
n'est pas parfait
dans l'amour.
Les Écritures nous disent aussi
que la crainte de l'homme
minimise la nature
de notre position en Christ.
Ça réduit la pensée
que nous avons
de notre position en Christ.
Je donne les références
Romains 8, 35 et 38 à 39
Qui nous séparera
de l'amour de Christ ?
Sera-t-il la tribulation
ou l'angoisse
ou la persécution
ou la faim
ou l'induité
ou le péril
ou l'épée ?
Car j'ai l'assurance
que ni la mort
ni la vie
ni les anges
ni les dominations
ni le présent
ni l'avenir
ni les puissances
ni la hauteur
ni la profondeur
ni aucune autre créature
ne pourra nous séparer
de l'amour de Dieu
manifesté en Jésus-Christ
notre Seigneur ?
Cette crainte
de l'homme
ne peut être surmontée
que par la puissance
de l'Évangile.
Donc là,
vous avez les références
là je ne vais pas
les lire là
mais je vous donne
les références
pour pouvoir lire après.
Romains 8
versets 31 à 34
1 Jean 4
versets 7 à 12
Et là,
toujours dans la continuité
de ce que les Écritures
nous disent
de la crainte de l'homme
nous allons prendre
quelques exemples
pour que nous puissions
comprendre
et être encouragés
que lorsque nous sommes
en train de traiter
ces choses
c'est un problème
universel
et notre besoin
c'est
le péché
est un problème
universel
et que
ça doit nous encourager
chaque fois
à fixer nos regards
sur Christ
souvent nous avons
beaucoup de tendance
à fixer nos regards
sur l'homme
et on va être déçu
de l'homme
et c'est parce que
quand nous sommes déçus
du pasteur
nous sommes déçus
de l'homme
c'est parce qu'à un moment
nous n'avons pas appris
à fixer le regard
sur celui
qui doit être
notre seul exemple
de perfection
Christ
donc des exemples
il y a Adam
que je venais de citer
dans Genèse 3
il y a Abraham
dans Genèse 12
versets 10 à 13
alors Abraham
à cette époque
il s'appelait encore Abraham
pas Abraham
Abraham
qui s'appelait alors
donc je reprends
Abraham
qui s'appelait Abraham
craignait que Pharaon
ne le tue
à cause de la beauté
de sa femme
il a alors proféré
une demi-vérité
c'est un mensonge
Abraham était le père
d'une nation
qui allait lutter
contre la peur
de l'homme
et là nous voyons
l'exemple
à travers l'exemple
d'Abraham
nous voyons
qu'il est faux
de croire
que céder la peur
de l'homme
n'aura d'autres effets
que sur nous-mêmes
Abraham va céder
à la peur de l'homme
il va mentir
et on voit les conséquences
qui vont avoir lieu
je vous laisse lire
le texte dans Genèse 12
10 à 13
mais on va voir
un moment
comment Dieu
va quand même
préserver ses hommes
de l'erreur
du péché d'Abraham
on a Lot
dans Genèse 19
Lot démontre
que crainte de l'homme
plus que Dieu
a des conséquences
bien au-delà
de nos propres vies
nous pouvons observer Lot
en particulier
sa crainte
des habitants
de Sodome et Gomorre
et les conséquences
que cette crainte
a eues sur sa famille
ses filles sont tombées
enceintes
de leur père
et sa femme
est devenue
une statue de sel
par amour
pour la ville
nous avons Jacob
dans Genèse 27
41 à 44
on voit Jacob
qui s'enfuit
de Labanne
donc de son
c'était son
oncle je crois
par peur
qu'ils aient eu
ah oui
Jacob
qui s'enfuit
vers Labanne
donc son oncle
par peur
qu'Esaïe
ne le tue
on a un autre exemple
on a Moïse
donc Moïse
dans Exode
dans Exode 2
11 à 17
je donne les références
pour les relire
nombre 20
9 à 13
on voit
Moïse
qui était alors
un jeune homme
qui s'enfuit
après avoir tué un homme
il est conscient
que son acte
pourrait lui valoir
un châtiment
et la mort
plus tard
à la tête d'Israël
donc ça c'est dans Exode
qu'on nous parle
de cet exemple
plus tard dans Nombre
on va nous parler
de cet exemple
où il va frapper
le rocher
à cause de sa colère
contre le peuple
ça va l'amener
à craindre
beaucoup plus le peuple
qu'à faire confiance
à Dieu
et donc Dieu lui avait dit
de parler au rocher
et Moïse
par rapport
à sa colère
vis-à-vis des hommes
il va frapper
le rocher
alors que ce n'était
pas ce que Dieu
lui avait ordonné
un autre exemple
il y a encore
d'autres exemples
on peut penser à Aaron
dans Exode 32
des versets 22 à 24
Aaron qui va céder
aux demandes
des Israélites
et qui va fabriquer
des idoles en or
qui va fabriquer
le veau d'or
et qui plus tard
va même expliquer
il va expliquer
que non
pourquoi il a fabriqué
le veau d'or
par crainte
du peuple d'Israël
on a Samson
dans Juge 14
qui va céder
aux harcèlements
de Delilah
et plus tard
dans sa réponse
à Delilah
sa peur de l'homme
va avoir un résultat
tragique
on a Saül
ça c'est un exemple
qu'on retient souvent
beaucoup
Saül dans sa jalousie
vis-à-vis de David
Saül même
dans sa disqualification
de roi
parce qu'à un moment
par crainte des hommes
un moment
il va désobéir
à ce que Samuel
lui avait recommandé
on peut penser à Jonas
Jonas
qui va manifester
sa crainte de l'homme
par sa haine
envers les hommes
de Ninive
on va penser
aux pharisiens
on peut penser
à Pierre
donc il y a
plusieurs exemples
là j'ai pris
quelques exemples
dans la Bible
mais quand je prends
ces exemples
dans la suite
de notre étude
on va pouvoir
revenir sur plusieurs
de ces exemples
pour nous permettre
de comprendre
comment les écritures
abordent la crainte
de l'homme
un peu plus en détail
et comment les écritures
aussi abordent
la crainte du Seigneur
donc
aujourd'hui
c'est de voir
où nous pouvons voir
la crainte des hommes
pourquoi
nous craignons les hommes
qu'est-ce que la Bible
dit de la crainte des hommes
mais aussi une chose
et là aussi
nous reviendrons
qu'en détail
quels sont les fruits
parce que souvent
vous voyez
un des aspects
il nous a été dit
à un moment
nous craignons les hommes
parce que nous avons
une vision à court terme
nous n'arrivons pas
à voir au-delà
des choses visibles
que nous voyons
et nous n'arrivons pas
alors à réaliser
quels sont les fruits
que la peur de l'homme
peut produire
dans notre vie
quel est le fruit
dans un sens
c'est assez difficile
de dire le fruit
que la peur de l'homme
peut produire
dans nos vies
mais la peur de l'homme
c'est déjà le fait
de ne pas vivre
dans la crainte du Seigneur
c'est une opposition
du fait que je crains
de l'homme
ça veut dire
que je ne crains
pas le Seigneur
du fait que je crains
l'homme
ça veut dire
que je manifeste
de l'orgueil
et je manifeste
de la dépendance
de ma vie
vis-à-vis de Dieu
et les fruits
que nous portons
quels sont les fruits
le fruit
on peut porter
c'est un fruit
avec de multiples facettes
la crainte de l'homme
va créer en nous
du mécontentement
si mon espoir
et ma confiance
reposent
sur l'opinion
des autres
je ne serai jamais
vraiment satisfait
donc à un moment
par crainte de l'homme
je vais persévérer
dans une voie
mais par crainte
de ce même homme
un moment
à cause de l'opinion
de ces hommes
je ne vais jamais
trouver de satisfaction
trouver de paix
quel est l'autre fruit
que produit
la crainte de l'homme
dans notre vie
elle va
créer une dépendance
malsaine
envers les autres
mon orientation
ne va pas être correcte
par conséquent
j'aurai besoin
des gens
d'une façon
d'une manière
malsaine
un moment
je vais être avec
les personnes
par intérêt
par crainte
je vais être
par crainte de l'homme
je vais être avec l'homme
mais j'ai des intérêts
et donc je préfère
craindre l'homme
plutôt que craindre Dieu
le fruit
un autre fruit
qui va être développé
par notre crainte de l'homme
ça va être du cynisme
si j'accorde
plus de valeur
à l'opinion des autres
qu'à celle du Seigneur
je vais devenir cynique
car je verrai
que les autres
ne peuvent pas supporter
le poids de mes attentes
c'est très difficile
et à un moment
ça nous amène
par cette crainte de l'homme
à un moment
et le problème
c'est que
nous ne pouvons pas
rejeter la faute sur Dieu
et nous devons
toujours être conscients
que quand nous cherchons
toujours à trouver
des excuses
pour rejeter
la faute sur Dieu
à cause de notre crainte
de l'homme
à cause d'un péché
nous devons toujours
nous souvenir
que chacun de nous
rendra compte à Dieu
et lorsque nous allons
rendre compte
la Bible nous dit
à un moment
que nous n'aurons pas
d'excuses
devant Dieu
vis-à-vis d'un péché
aujourd'hui nous pouvons
trouver des excuses
même vis-à-vis
de la crainte de l'homme
on peut trouver
plusieurs excuses
pour justifier
pourquoi nous pouvons
craindre l'homme
dans un certain domaine
de notre vie
dans une certaine attitude
mais devant Dieu
lorsque Dieu
va juger
nos actions
les motivations
dans notre cœur
nous ne pourrons pas
utiliser ces mêmes excuses
mais aujourd'hui
souvent ça va créer
du cynisme
j'ai rencontré
beaucoup de personnes
qui sont devenues cyniques
par la crainte
des hommes
souvent
beaucoup de non-croyants
à cause de ça
excusez-moi
j'avais mis le
non non non
c'était
réveil
abattu
voilà
donc
on va être cynique
parce que les gens
ne peuvent pas supporter
le poids de nos attentes
une autre chose
que va créer
le mécontentement
le cynisme
ça va amener
l'amertume
la crainte de l'homme
va créer l'amertume
à un moment il y a des personnes
elles vont être amères
dans leur travail
dans ce qu'elles vivent
mais elles supportent ça
parce qu'elles craignent l'homme
mais elles vivent
avec l'amertume
elles n'ont plus de joie
au travail
mais comme il y a
le salaire qui tombe
on va supporter
tel ou tel
là je prends un exemple
comme ça
mais il y a tellement
d'exemples
que je peux prendre
je peux prendre là dessus
là la deuxième question
la première question
je vous avais dit
à partir de ce qu'on avait
déjà développé
comment
vous pouvez voir
si vous pouvez voir
des exemples de crainte
de l'homme
dans votre vie
là ce serait aussi
de réfléchir
comment vous voyez
le fruit
est-ce que vous voyez
un fruit
de la peur de l'homme
dans votre vie
un de ces fruits
qu'on vient de citer
du mécontentement
une dépendance
malsaine envers les autres
du cynisme
ou de l'amertume
et ça nous amène aussi
sur ce
le cinquième point
qui sera
qu'est-ce que le monde
fait de la peur
de l'homme
comment le monde
traite la peur
de l'homme
donc là
on a
là on a
longuement réfléchi
à la façon
dont la peur
de l'homme
est ancrée en nous
aux effets
qu'elle peut avoir
et la façon
dont elle peut même
être ancrée
dans notre culture
et c'est pour nous
c'est aussi important
de pouvoir prendre
là maintenant
un moment aussi
pour réfléchir
dans la façon
dont le monde
décrit la peur
de l'homme
là on a vu
comment les écritures
décrivent
la peur
la crainte de l'homme
la peur de l'homme
mais là aussi
nous allons aussi
aborder un peu
comment le monde
décrit la peur
de l'homme
comment le monde
y fait face
et même comment le monde
l'utilise pour son avantage
parce qu'on voit
un moment
comment dans ce monde
on voit comment
certains peuvent même
exploiter la peur
de l'homme
chez les autres
alors comment
le monde le décrit
de plusieurs façons
on va le décrire
dans le monde
on va voir
que la peur
de l'homme
se manifeste
par la codépendance
par la pression sociale
par le perfectionnisme
à un moment
les gens vont devoir
être parfaits
parce qu'à un moment
ils ont leur chef
pour ce travail
dont ils ont besoin
il faut qu'ils soient
parfaits dans tout
il faut qu'ils sacrifient
leur vie
à un moment
tu passes un entretien
on te dit
dès que vous aurez
ce travail
sachez que vous n'aurez
plus de vie
mais comme vous aurez
un bon salaire
on va le prendre
par crainte de l'homme
on accepte
quelque chose comme ça
de se sacrifier
on peut même
appeler ça
vendre son âme
on va vendre son âme
pour pouvoir
gagner plus
l'égoïsme
donc le monde
le monde va nous montrer
à un moment
que la peur de l'homme
dans le monde
se décrit
par la dépendance
malsaine
la pression sociale
le perfectionnisme
l'égoïsme
les discours
sur l'estime de soi
aujourd'hui même
dans notre société
on a les mâles alpha
on a le féminisme
on a des personnalités
de type A
de type B
enfin on a beaucoup
un peu lié
au développement personnel
tout ça
donc qu'est-ce que le monde
fait aujourd'hui
pour aider les gens
à surmonter la peur
de l'homme
on prend le terme
surmonter
parce que
beaucoup de gens
car il y a
dans la façon
dont ils décrivent ça
il y a peu de choses
qui sont vraiment
des solutions miracles
aujourd'hui
on vit dans une
ère de la thérapie
mais
la triste réalité
qu'il y a
c'est que
même au sein
de nos églises
on est beaucoup
affecté par ça
aujourd'hui
l'estime de soi
le développement personnel
sont des enseignements
centraux
il y a même
des prédications
vous voyez
quelqu'un qui vient
prêcher un dimanche
il va prêcher
sur le développement
personnel
et non sur la Bible
il va juste
prendre un verset
et puis tout le reste
je me souviens
avant d'être
de rentrer dans la
foi réformée
j'étais souvent surpris
par quelques églises
dont je ne citerai pas
les noms
et quand j'écoutais
leurs prédications
en fait
c'était le même discours
qu'un discours
de développement personnel
que j'aurais écouté
quelque part
la seule différence
c'est qu'ils avaient
pris un verset biblique
avant
mais sinon après
tout le reste
j'avais déjà écouté ça
dans un cours
de développement personnel
mais malheureusement
la façon dont le monde
fait face à l'échec
le monde fait face
à la peur de l'homme
au lieu que l'église
apporte la solution
de l'évangile
beaucoup d'églises
se sont laissées
influencer par le modèle
thérapeutique
des conseillers laïcs
que parce que les écritures
nous disent à ce sujet
donc vous connaissez
pour ceux qui ont déjà
pu entendre
Albert Moller
qu'est-ce qu'il va dire
à ce sujet
il dit
nous vivons à une époque
où la question principale
que se pose la plupart
des gens est
est-ce que je vais bien
ce qu'il veut dire
c'est que
est-ce que je vais bien
ils sont en train
de poser la question
au sens psychologique
du terme
c'est la réalité
pour beaucoup de personnes
aujourd'hui en Occident
il est normal
qu'on leur dise
que le soi
est au centre
du système de sens
et que le soi
est un projet
qu'ils poursuivent
tout au long
de leur vie
par conséquent
beaucoup d'occidentaux
croient que leur problème
majeur est quelque chose
qui leur est arrivé
et que la solution
se trouve en eux
encore là
j'ai réalisé ça
un moment
là j'avais vu
c'est quelqu'un
qui se dit chrétien
qui va dire
un moment
beaucoup n'ont pas compris
l'oeuvre de Christ
parce qu'ils sont en train
de chercher le Christ
ailleurs
alors que le Christ
se trouve en eux
et là quand il parle
on nous a dit
nous sommes des petits dieux
nous sommes des dieux
donc à un moment
toutes ces choses là
c'est en nous
que nous devons les trouver
donc
il croit
autrement dit
il croit avoir
un problème étranger
qui doit être résolu
par une solution
intérieure
or ce que dit l'évangile
c'est que nous avons
non pas un problème
étranger
mais nous avons
un problème intérieur
qui exige
une solution étrangère
donc le monde
inverse
le monde va dire
un moment
nous avons un problème
étranger
la solution intérieure
se trouve en moi
mais la Bible
nous dit un moment
que le problème
se trouve en moi
et que la solution
est extérieure
la solution c'est Christ
à la croix
donc c'est une justice
qui n'est pas la nôtre
et
si vous allez
dans toutes les cultures
selon les cultures
la peur de l'homme
est vécue
de diverses manières
même si nous abordons
ce sujet
en tant que chrétien
qui vivons
dans une culture
occidentale
nous devons être conscients
et peut-être
même encore plus conscients
puisque certains
d'entre nous
ne sont pas issus
de la culture occidentale
moi par exemple
en venant d'Afrique
j'ai pu voir
que dans d'autres cultures
la crainte de l'homme
peut se manifester
différemment
ainsi dans de nombreuses
cultures
asiatiques et africaines
l'accent est mis
sur la relation familiale
la crainte de l'homme
va beaucoup se manifester
dans la famille
la peur de l'homme
et l'expérience de la honte
peuvent prendre
une dimension
plus communautaire
donc par exemple
ici en Europe
on va être beaucoup plus
dans un relativisme
un détachement
mais au niveau
des communautés
par exemple
asiatiques et africaines
je ne sais pas
sud-américaines
si ça va être le cas
souvent ça va être
les chefs de famille
qui vont avoir
une autorité
qui va même au-delà
de ce que la Bible
recommande
un moment sur beaucoup
de choses
et ça ne va pas être
biblique
et même
on va même transposer
ça aux pasteurs
dans l'église
on va avoir même
des
souvent on a parlé
même de cet aspect
où souvent on va avoir
des églises africaines
et même asiatiques
où les gens servent
beaucoup
les gens servent
les gens participent
à beaucoup de réunions
mais ils le font
non pas de façon volontaire
ils le font par crainte
de l'homme
parce qu'à un moment
il y a la crainte
liée à la culture
qui va faire un moment
qu'il y a le châtiment
si tu te sors
de la communauté
il y a le châtiment
qui vient avec
donc à un moment
on sert à l'église
non pas à cause
de la crainte du Seigneur
on sert par la crainte
de l'homme
on peut dire
même au sein
de notre ville
où nous pouvons être
à Paris par exemple
il y a différentes
sous-cultures
qui vont opérer
au sein d'une culture
plus large
mais pourtant
l'essentiel
même pour ça
quand on va parler
de ça
ce n'est pas la diversité
des manifestations
de ce combat
mais c'est le coeur
du problème
aujourd'hui
le problème du monde
c'est de toujours
vouloir examiner
la multitude
des manifestants
le problème du monde
c'est de toujours
ne jamais vouloir
traiter la racine
du problème
le monde veut toujours
traiter les conséquences
et il ne veut jamais
aborder de face
quelle est la racine
du problème
la racine du problème
se trouve
par rapport au péché
la crainte de l'homme
ne peut pas être résolue
par le fait
de traiter
les conséquences extérieures
pour que la crainte
de l'homme
soit traitée
il faudrait
qu'elle soit traitée
à partir de l'origine
de notre coeur
et donc on voit
qu'au niveau
du monde
le monde
voudrait plutôt
examiner
la multitude
de manifestations
de craintes des hommes
pour élaborer
une sorte de modèle
pour chacune d'elles
en croyant à un moment
que c'est ça
qui va permettre
de sortir de ça
donc on va te dire
à un moment
voilà les 5 étapes
pour ne plus craindre
d'un homme
alors que ça
ça ne va pas servir
à grand chose
mais ça va toujours
détourner notre attention
des véritables causes
et de la solution
donc ce que je suis
en train de dire
ça a toujours été
le problème
c'est à dire
aujourd'hui nous parlons
de la crainte des hommes
mais quel que soit
le péché qui se manifeste
dans une société
vous allez voir
que le monde
ne veut jamais traiter
la racine du problème
le monde veut toujours
traiter les conséquences
et par rapport à ça
un peu sur la conclusion
pour notre conclusion
ce soir
est-ce que
parce que la question
qui peut se poser
on peut dire
c'est universel
à un moment
c'est tout à fait normal
aussi dans un certain sens
qu'on puisse craindre l'homme
on va avoir du respect
pour notre responsable
pour notre mari
de toutes ces choses-là
donc on peut se poser
est-ce qu'il y a
une peur légitime de l'homme
par rapport à une peur
une peur pécheresse de l'homme
et comment nous pouvons
faire la distinction
entre les deux
d'une peur légitime de l'homme
et une peur pécheresse
ce qui est important pour nous
lorsque nous sommes en train
de traiter ces choses
c'est pas de donner l'impression
qu'il n'existe pas
de manière juste et appropriée
de craindre autrui
il est juste
dans le sens où nous allons
lui témoigner du respect
le respect qui lui est dû
donc la Bible va nous dire
un moment
de craindre Dieu
de respecter le roi
la Bible va nous demander
de craindre nos autorités
dans un sens de respect
la Bible va nous demander
de craindre nos parents
d'avoir du respect
pour nos parents
il est juste d'éprouver
de la peur
ça va être juste
d'éprouver de la peur
face à des situations
physiquement dangereuses
et donc il serait insensé
d'aborder le danger
avec des envoltures
à hasard
donc là
quand je suis en train
de parler de ça
je ne suis pas en train
de dire un moment
que je pense que vous
reprennez dans le sens
ça peut être tout à fait
normal qu'on éprouve
de la peur
par rapport à quelque chose
il n'est pas mal
il n'est pas
c'est pas un péché
de désirer
que les autres
nous approuvent
ou nous acceptent
c'est tout à fait normal
il n'est pas mal
de désirer
que chaque facette
de notre vie
ne soit pas exposée
à tous
mais la peur d'autrui
devient un péché
lorsqu'elle gouverne
notre vie
elle devient un péché
lorsque nous franchissons
la ligne
entre le plaisir
de l'approbation
des autres
et la conviction
que nous en avons besoin
ou que nous la méritons
nous pouvons désirer
l'approbation
un enfant
qui va aller
à un spectacle
un moment
tous les enfants
même quand nous allons
être plus grands
si par exemple
tu as même déjà
25-26 ans
que tu es en train
d'avoir ta remise
de diplôme
dans la salle
tu vas chercher
tes parents
du regard
parce qu'il y a
cette approbation
que tu recherches
elle n'est pas mauvaise
mais si cette peur
d'autrui
devient un péché
qu'elle gouverne
notre vie
ou ce désir
d'approbation
des hommes
va maintenant
conduire à une conviction
qu'il nous faut
absolument
l'approbation
des hommes
alors là
nous sommes
dans une situation
de péché
lorsque nous sommes
tellement saisis
par la peur
d'être blessés
physiquement
que nous refusons
de vivre
comme le Seigneur
nous a appelé
à vivre dans ce monde
ça ça devient
déjà un péché
lorsque
nous ne voulons
pas vivre
comme des étrangers
des pèlerins
qui sont conscients
qui peuvent connaître
les douleurs physiques
la difficulté
là ça devient
déjà un péché
la vie chrétienne
n'est pas une quête
inutile de douleur
ça il faut toujours
qu'on soit clair
Dieu n'est pas en train
de nous appeler
à souffrir
il n'est pas en train
de nous appeler
à avoir des douleurs
il n'est pas en train
de nous appeler
à souffrir
à être rejeté
à être exposé
gratuitement
comme ça
nous devons toujours
savoir à un moment
que lorsque nous sommes
en train
de vivre
la douleur
la souffrance
le rejet
l'exposition
l'abus
Dieu est en train
de se glorifier
dans nos vies
pour nous qui sommes
croyants
nous devons comprendre
un moment
que plus nous sommes
en train
d'être exposés
à ces choses
et que nous dépendons
de la grâce de Dieu
et plus nous allons voir
Christ être en train
de grandir en nous
et donc c'est important
de pouvoir préciser
ça va être tout à fait normal
on peut avoir peur
on peut avoir des craintes
on peut avoir ces choses
mais ces choses
ne doivent pas gouverner
il ne faut pas maintenant
qu'à cause de ces choses
à un moment
à cause de la crainte
des hommes
nous ayons
voilà ce que
Pierre et Jean
vont dire à un moment
quand on les a fouettés
et qu'on les sort
et qu'on leur dit
ne parlez plus
de ce Jésus
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont dire
il vaut mieux avoir
peur
ou crainte de Dieu
plutôt
que les hommes
là je paraphrase
comme je suis un peu
voilà
mais vous comprenez
voilà c'était ça
donc ils vont dire
à un moment
nous préférons
avoir peur de Dieu
si nous ne partageons
pas ce message
plutôt que de vous
même si vous nous fouettez
ou vous nous tuez
et là où ça peut être
dangereux
c'est si cette crainte
de l'homme
maintenant nous empêche
même
de ne pas vouloir
la persécution
parce que si les gens
savent que je suis chrétien
ça va
ça peut me compliquer
la vie
si les gens savent
que je ne bois pas
d'alcool
par exemple
j'arrive
je suis étudiant
et là
à un moment
on va me proposer
une bière
je devrais dire non
mais j'ai peur
des réactions
que les gens
vont me dire
ah encore
ces chrétiens
qui ne savent pas
vivre
donc à un moment
par peur de l'homme
je vais dire oui
on va même se dire
à un moment
je vais trouver l'excuse
c'est pour m'insérer
dans le lien social
non
nous savons à un moment
la vérité qu'il y a
donc
par conclusion
la conclusion pour ce soir
la conclusion
qui peut être apportée
et c'est
voilà pourquoi
je voulais apporter
cet aspect
c'est pour dire
que c'est sans vouloir
être réducteur
on ne veut pas être réducteur
par rapport à ça
sans vouloir être réducteur
nous craignons l'homme
parce que nous ne craignons pas
Dieu
ou que nous ne craignons pas
Dieu assez
voilà pourquoi déjà
la manifestation
de la crainte de l'homme
se manifeste
chaque fois que nous
nous abandonnons
à la crainte de l'homme
nous choisissons
de nous aimer davantage
et de craindre
de moins craindre Dieu
voilà
l'ecclésiaste
va conclure
par cet avertissement
craigner Dieu
et observer ses commandements
c'est là
tout le devoir
de l'homme
car
et c'est ce que je vous ai dit
Dieu va emmener
toute œuvre en jugement
même tout ce qui est caché
que ce soit bien
ou que ce soit mal
et donc
pour nous
c'est important
de comprendre un moment
que nous devons
restaurer la perspective
biblique
c'est de voir
un moment
à long terme
c'est de voir un moment
que la crainte de l'homme
peut me priver
de certaines choses
ici bas
peut me priver
même de perdre
des choses
qui peuvent même
être importantes
en ma vie
mais la crainte de Dieu
m'apporte
davantage de privilèges
non seulement
dans cette vie maintenant
dans un monde déchu
mais aussi
pour le futur
et on verra
par la suite
donc aujourd'hui
nous allons nous arrêter là
mais pour la suite
on pourra commencer
un peu à comprendre
aussi ce principe
de la crainte de Dieu
parce que tant que
nous n'aurons pas bien
saisi
ce que la parole de Dieu
nous enseigne
au sujet de la crainte
du Seigneur
nous ne pourrons pas
aborder la crainte
de l'homme
dans nos vies
tant que nous ne comprenons
pas un moment
nous ne saisissons pas
cette crainte de Dieu
c'est difficile de comprendre
pourquoi
Paul pouvait dire
à un moment
la mort mettait un gain
pourquoi Paul était même prêt
à perdre sa vie
pour gagner Christ
gloire à Dieu